thank you
[Music]
all right this story to me was just
funny because it has so many features of
like rich people elements and that's
really it it's like if you took all the
rich people stuff out of the story it
would be like a nothing story yeah but
just listen to this rich people problems
so this is in Palm Beach right so it's
like crazy Rich Asians right or crazy
Rich anybody like oh get a seeking the
approval of the parent or whatever but
it's just because uh Singapore took lots
of money
the details of it are just they just
sound ridiculous to me uh so you got a
66 year old woman in Palm Beach she's
driving a 2021 Rolls-Royce Dawn which is
a 360
000 car oh [__] for reasons unknown she
accidentally plows through this home's
yard
um because it costs more than a home
probably right yeah but this home is
actually really nice
she ends up in the backyard and then
she's trying to get out of the backyard
and she's like churning and [__] she
hits the statue on her way out of the
yard and uh did you say that driver was
a woman yeah okay
your honor I just wanted to no to notice
that your honor Okay cool so um after
she hits a statue she ends up crashing
into the like two more walls in the back
and they just end up in this ditch
um and the statue it turns out to be a
three million dollar statue yep she has
to pay for all of it and it turns out
that the home she crashed into is owned
by a guy named Stephen Tannenbaum who is
famous for his 47 billion dollar hedge
fund
wasn't there a movie called The Royal
tenem bombs yeah it's not related okay
so rich that that ball and ass house he
doesn't even live in he lives he
actually lives in this one okay so did
he come out like
like the hell
or he sent us Butler go tell him what
the hell
he has a what the hell
the hell and then there's that YouTuber
in his front door like what do you do
for a living
so what happened so she really can't for
the life of her know why she did this
she doesn't have anymore I know why it
doesn't have any uh because how old is
she 66. should she be driving at 66 you
shouldn't be but no but not no no no no
not all 66 year olds are created equal
though true you know what I mean some
people are 60 yeah where you see them
talking you're like 95 looking yeah I
mean you're right so it's like I know
some 66 year olds who are like the
they're really fit and you know they're
that's great and they're very cognizant
but yeah a lot younger like they got
that Benjamin Button that's what I mean
25. yeah yeah she's um I'm a suit I
would imagine she's one of those 66 year
olds I love how all these stories we've
been reading today have really bad
excuses for why people did these really
dumb things yeah yeah I just don't know
how did this happen yeah she said her
mind's kind of a blank like she doesn't
remember anything before she was like oh
I crashed you're not that old like she
accidentally painted the back side of
her sunglasses
[Laughter]
maybe you shouldn't drive yeah I mean so
what what's the question here
I mean there's no real question it's
just she's she's Rich enough to pay for
what happened oh she could pay for it
all yeah she's Rich too it's a rich
Community she's one of the people in the
community not principle she should
because you can't cause that much damage
and then just like I mean this is
dementia like she's got some serious
health issues yeah I mean
paying that is like you know we
accidentally reversed instead of going
forward and then we went into our
neighbor's yard and knocked over their
gnome yeah and then they're like dude
you owe me
and you're like well I guess I have to
exactly that's why I find it funny
scaled up version of like [__] that just
happened yeah but is it that she's you
know like maybe rich people also have a
difference to the backyard they're like
we're gonna say some conniving [__] no
like you know like uh if you're kind of
smart with tax you kind of know what to
say and when if you're smart with crime
you kind of know what to say oh her vow
of like I don't remember anything could
just be how you get through a lot of
[__] and then make this a tax deduction
or something yeah it could be yeah wow
like I don't think it's like I'm old I
don't remember there's smarter ways of
handling it 66 you obviously have a
massive net worth or yeah you're not
dumb I wonder also if it's like a way
you know some of your lifetime movies
and all those other stories I've been
talking about today what if she's
actually [__] her husband over by
doing this
that's good that's a good development
pay for that statue and this and that
and she doesn't remember so she can't
medically be liable oh wow oh yeah the
liability goes yeah it could be a more
sophisticated he's [__] that fake
mechanic okay yeah I'm gonna crash the
rolls into those [__] million dollars
oops that's
oh what are the odds I hit it with this
rolls right there's a deeper plot it's
probably coincidental yeah yeah she knew
that statue was three million had a
blank it's either that or she completely
just lost her mind like I think it's
either two choices right now our two
choices are are girls really stupid and
dumb yeah or really conniving yeah
yeah it's one of the other so much
passion I think women are so smart I
think they're way smarter than me I
think they're smart too
smarts to poison your husband slowly
with Drano or to piss off your husband
by purposely crashing a Rolls-Royce into
a three million dollar statue with
Billionaire's backyard yeah they're just
too intentional yeah it cannot be an
accident dude
instead of like I was trying to kill
ants and I was trying to and I forgot
what happened
or it could be it could be a thing where
like her lawyer is just really good and
was like all right you just say you
don't remember anything and we'll handle
yeah it sounds like a bad lawyer because
she could have been like I was on my
phone
arguing with my husband
she could have been saying but actually
we're not going to tell the truth right
now by the way in the video of this
happening there's no video but there's
like a description of it she so she
initially crashes into the house she's
stopped she turns and then hits the
statue yeah that is what Christians say
so she's kind of like a bull in a china
shop
there's no way you accidentally hit a
three million dollar statue I think we
underestimate how panicked people get in
a billionaire neighborhood all the
houses on that block yeah they're
massive she hit the one with a three
million dollar statue in the backyard
she nothing but net she's
[Laughter]
and those houses are probably the length
of this block yeah true true yes yes she
could have hit a lot she could have she
avoided the tennis court avoided the
[__] swimming pool she hit the just
think about it right dude she [__] up
she drove all the way in and she's she
probably broke a gate she did she's
she's [__] up the yard she avoided
that two people riding horses yeah and
she's already like oh [__] like because
dude when you hit when I hit the trash
can sometimes I go oh my God my heart
beats out of my chest
so I can only imagine what it feels like
when you hit another car or anything and
your car just keep going yeah I think
some people some people's response is
like they panic and they free they hit
another thing yeah they hit another
thing I've had two trash cans in one day
no you know what I mean not but you're a
dude her distance she went though she
had to go the length of this massive
driveway to even get to where the house
actually was yeah and then she hit a
bunch of [__] and you know when you're
in the backyard took some turns there
had to be something else she was a
pinball yeah yeah because you know when
you're in a real balling neighborhood
everyone's walls are like those bushes
that are like as [__] two stories
high right you can't even see the house
see the house so she had to go through
that
first fortification absolutely yeah she
went to go through that line of defense
got through kept going some people have
a moat yeah I think she's probably
[__] the dude who lives there or or
the husband's [__] somebody else
because either she wanted the dude's
wife to know or somebody wanted somebody
else to know so using the potential
potential of your writer's brain what's
the plot oh yeah I see I just did the
Tenon bomb dude like being there
afterwards like to his wife like damn
that was crazy huh and the wife is like
so you're telling me
[Laughter]
you're telling me this [__] randomly
hit our house in the sad she's like yeah
I don't know that sounds crazy
she randomly crashes into the statue's
penis too yeah I don't know honey she
said she forgot I believe her I just
think she looks like a truthful person I
think this was a message being sent yeah
it's kind of like uh like dark night
when that dude's about to snitch on who
Bruce Wayne is so he runs the lambo into
the he's like what who did I hit yeah
it's like that situation it's like okay
dude this fantastic thing just happened
right yeah it sounds like some Gone Girl
[__] you guys seen Gone Girl Gone Girl
[__] it sounds like some plan to do
something else it could be and guess
what if it is one of those situations
and somebody is involved with some other
[__] they're not let the story out the
story helps all of them stay quiet like
I'm like yeah sure whatever as long as
the real story that's true I'm sure the
neighbors are the Realty you're gonna be
the neighbors that tell you the real
[__] or could this somehow maybe be some
kind of a laundering thing where you
spend that much money on a statue and
then you have an insurance policy on it
yeah and it gets destroyed this train is
on a train situation yeah you ever seen
that movie Alfred Hitchcock two
Strangers Like This is a famous tennis
player and this random ass dude just
meet in the train at the same time and
they start drinking on their way to
wherever they're going they're talking
about how they both hate their Ex-Wives
like I am Ex-Wives she's take out my
money I hate Max why she won't send the
divorce papers and so the stranger guy
is like hey we should just swap murders
we have no connection if you got off
here and killed my ex-wife and I got off
there and killed your ex-wife and we
both bounce there'd be no way for anyone
to ask these murders and then the tennis
player is like haha one but the crazy
stranger goes and does the murder oh
[__] I killed your ex-wife you got to
kill mine now oh yeah but then there's
like no way to the trace these guys have
no connection they've met on a train
yeah I never saw each other again
listening to me we're gonna watch it
strangers on a train wow Hitchcock movie
why why did you say it that like that it
sounds like a good movie
[Laughter]
there's a neighborhood in Florida where
um every single house has like a pilot
or like a airplane oh like a landing
strip well they I think they might share
the landing strip oh the garage every
single house has a garage just for
planes it's like a pilot's Dream It's
like where John Travolta lives how he's
got his own like yeah they have their
own airplane Hangar yeah and then it's
like the whole neighborhood just uses
planes there's a race track how's it
going out here right I think
yeah there's like a community like yup
they built a community for everyone who
has like race cars and like there's a
track like either inside or just outside
the community that's so cool it's like
constantly being used yeah they got like
garages with doors on both sides where's
that you just go out somewhere out here
that's crazy that would be very loud
like imagine trying to sleep in your
hair but that's why that's why if you
live there you're down with this [__]
yeah there's a lot of secret
neighborhoods you know that like you
know there's a lake in L.A that it's
like a gated it's like a gated community
one that's up the hills yeah like I was
just like um when I was like look we're
actually gonna settle down I was trying
to just find if there's any really
unique type of neighborhoods and I found
that I'm like what the [__] I never knew
it was like wait the one in Hollywood or
the one in Pasadena there's it's in
Hollywood area yeah but it's a gated
community and almost no one sells our
house so you can't even go to it yeah
you can't even walk in I only saw it
because I was on a helicopter tour of LA
and I was like what the [__] is that
yeah
what about when we film The the Asian
um Bachelor that one Mansion
um that one that that's like an Hacienda
Heights or something no it's in
Hollywood
and then in the backyard it was like a
lake too it was it was like a weird I
was like what the hell there's a there's
a lake here out of nowhere or like a
reservoir yeah the lake you're talking
about is technically a reservoir yeah oh
is it yeah yeah so yeah because I've oh
wait you weren't in that one you were in
the first one or the different scene
yeah but the house that we filmed at it
might be that Lake you're talking about
oh yeah it's like a bunch of mansions
yeah fellow mansions and then in his
backyard there's like a a little Lake in
a reservoir thing yeah some of the some
of the pads have direct Lake access and
then uh they just never sell because
they know it's always going to go up in
value so it's even hard to get into that
neighborhood oh my God yeah that's so
cool telling you guys about Canyon Lake
oh yeah that little community so it's a
city that's um it's near like Lake
Elsinore okay and um it's the it's the
country's largest gated community and
it's an entire city built around like a
lake and you you literally cannot go in
there unless you're a resident and it's
like a whole secret it's kind of like a
best kept secret whole city Canyon Lake
yeah and you can go on YouTube and watch
this where's that is that off the five
or something I don't know if it's off
the five where's Lake Elsinore it's like
uh Inland and more Inland yeah but it's
like it's crazy because
um I found it by just buying something
on OfferUp and the guy was like oh are
you a Canyon Lake resident I'm like nah
and he's like oh I can't you can't come
in here then and I was like what the
[__] was that and then and then so I
looked it up and then I found their
YouTube channel they have like an
internal Channel that's just like what's
going on in Canyon Lake today we've got
some boating over at Rob's and then it's
like such local like things about wow
like Nancy's got some extra quilts ready
for you guys it's like this weird that's
a culture yeah that's some weird [__]
you can't even make a sale on offer up
it looks so beautiful unless you're a
resident you can't get in there you're
not you have to be signed in or some
[__] oh and then like if you're a guest
they have to yeah and I think it's like
it's kind of like real that's what I
said yeah look it's just this place oh
[__] and it's it's all gated up yeah
yeah yeah it's like the real Bros of
Canyon Lake
oh [__] and no one ever talks about this
place it's like so under the radar
[Music]